now for something a little bit different
swipe is a tech show you know that so
you're used to watching us try out new
innovations to see if they might help
improve our lives but rarely do we look
at what happens when tech might not be
100% helpful one of the world's
best-selling relationship authors was in
the UK recently I went to meet him and
he had a lot to tell me about how he
thinks technology is affecting our love
lives John Gray is one of the
best-selling relationship authors of all
time
he was once a celibate monk for nine
years that was before he became famous
for his men are from Mars Women are from
Venus self-help books in the 1990s back
in the days when no-one had a smartphone
technologies had a huge impact on the
quality of our relationship it's it's
like a distraction that absorbs us
almost like a bottle of alcohol you know
you can drinking is fun but too much is
not a good thing going online is fun
it's good but too much of it pulls us
away from the normal stimulation of a
relationship people don't understand
that digital electronic stimulation is
similar to drugs in terms of the brain
chemical it produces dopamine dopamine
is that which creates the brain chemical
that creates attraction between men and
women but when you're dependent when
you're being stimulated through the news
all the time and the Facebook and the
massive amount of information is coming
in it overwhelms the brain with dopamine
so normal stimulation of dopamine
doesn't affect us anymore and the same
thing happens with children today the
best babysitter is just give them an
iPad and let them play their games what
parents don't realize is too much of
that actually changes their brain just
like a drug addict it causes you to
become dependent upon high stimulation
in order to feel alive and normal
stimulation is kind of boring and flat
so for the younger generation and for
the older generation relationships are
becoming kind of flat and boring and
people need to do all kinds of things to
sort of spice it up and create the
attraction again why women gain weight
after marriage and men don't John's note
ante tag he's got a YouTube channel and
online blog giving relationship advice
doesn't mean we can't have technology
and good relationships I'm pointing out
that with technology with more women in
the workplace women being financially
independent without depending on a man
with those new challenges in our
relationships new skills can help us to
resolve that we all know dating apps a
big business the simplicity of flicking
through profiles and spotting faces you
fancy but half swiping right killed
romance it's very easy to just move on
from one person to the next to the next
and it's important to slow the whole
process down and what would slow the
process down if women would slow down
it's like they have the doors the man's
job is to get earned the key to open the
door and for anyone already through the
doors and in a relationship so what
would your top three tips for men and
for women be to survive and be happy in
this stress and tech filled world so
three points for men be good listeners
plan dates and show affection and if
you're angry have to have the fourth and
if you're angry stop talking and do
something to rebuild your testosterone
your heart will open and come back and
be more loving and for women the three
points is when you see your husband
first time always be happy to see him no
matter what's going on inside of you be
happy to see him for a minute and then
ignore him
just give him that message that he
you're happy he's alive men need that
learn these new techniques of how to
share what's going on inside of you
but it's not about him and number three
you go in for the hug and you appreciate
him for all that he does